virginia governor glenn younkin who is
joining us live today from virginia
beach where he is about to hold an event
touting plans for to lower taxes for
virginians governor thank you so much
it's great to have you with us today um
thanks for joining us thank you martha i
want to start by asking you it's great
to have you sir um president biden is in
your state today and he's talking about
expanding spending programs uh the bbb
and sort of reviving that why do you
think that that is what's on his agenda
today in your home state
well first of all everybody wants to
come to virginia now martha we're
getting taxes down we're improving
education we're getting our economy
moving we're investing in law
enforcement to get crime down and we're
standing up for our constitutional
rights so so i invite president biden
anybody else who wants to come to
virginia
because it's an exciting place to be
right now i also am very excited about
the fact that delaware his home state
actually just decided that they were
going to allow parents to make decisions
whether their kids are going to be
masked or not and that's what we're
pressing forward in virginia we've been
leading on this for a year i'm so
excited we have a bipartisan effort to
bring that about in virginia so i
welcome him to virginia and i hope that
he has a great day
yeah
but in terms of what he's pressing he he
wants to expand spending at the federal
level uh we have inflation at seven and
a half percent and he was also with
allison spanberger the representative to
congress of course and she's in a
district that trump won handily do you
think that's politically
politically apt for her to be with him
today
well
first of all we do have runaway
inflation and it's just completely
driven by a lack of discipline in our
federal spending and to see inflation at
seven raised seven percent last year and
there's expectations that it'll be at
least another six percent this year uh
it's just running away from us and we're
seeing it on a on a at the ground level
across virginia grocery prices going up
housing prices going up service prices
going up virginians are really
frustrated with this and and so i don't
think this is going to play well
for the president in in virginia as
we're working to get exp costs down
we're working to cut taxes eliminate our
grocery tax double our standard
deduction have a very large tax rebate
exclude forty thousand dollars of our
veterans retirement benefits from being
taxed and oh by the way suspend the most
recent nickel increase in our gas tax we
have got to get prices down the one
thing i can do is get taxes down and i
really wish washington would do a much
better job of understanding the dynamics
of supply and demand well that's not you
know taking taxes down isn't something
that we hear a lot of uh today at all
and as a governor you can certainly push
for that in your home state and we'll
see how you do with that you talk about
going to the store you went to the store
the other day and uh you got heckled
here's just a little snippet of that i
want to get your reaction to what
happened
so you didn't have a mask on and i love
that last person who says read the room
buddy you're in alexandria um what did
you think about that
well of course we're making change and
we're standing up for parents we're
empowering parents to make decisions for
their children it's happening on a
bipartisan basis we've just gotten a
bill through our senate it'll go through
the house we'll get this in effect over
the next two weeks and we're gonna we're
gonna give parents the power that they
deserve to make decisions for their kids
you know when we're starting we're
talking about reading the room
virginia's been leading in this for the
last year the rest of the nation is now
all of a sudden recognizing we must get
back to normal and we have to give our
kids the ability to get back to normal
to fully participate in education
because we have watched this mandatory
mass culture where we give parents no
ability to choose to actually work
against our children we're watching
fallen behind in school we're learning
development challenges and so if parents
want their child to wear a mask please
have them wear it but if parents don't
want their child to wear a mask we're
going to give them the ability to make
that decision yeah it's interesting
jen's hockey yesterday said it's our
view that if a student or parent wants
to ch chooses to wear a mask they should
be able to freely so that and they
shouldn't be prevented from doing that i
haven't heard you say a single time that
you thought that some anyone who would
like to wear a mask should be prevented
from wearing it um so i thought that was
a very interesting comment on her part i
want to get your thought on one other
thing because there's something now
called the yunkan effect after your
very stunning election in in virginia
which really sent out a lot of waves
this is from barry weiss's sub stack
today got a lot of attention and they're
labeling essentially a new group of
voters called the covid moms who are
angry about the way this has been
handled
it reminds me of the soccer moms the
security moms and clearly this is of the
moment so here's one of them who's
running for office in new york against
carolyn maloney who's been in office for
30 years watch this
you can be 60 70 80 years old and go sit
in a restaurant indoors
for hours and have a meal together but
my five-year-old can't have 30 minutes
with his friends at recess and and play
without a mask on and run without a mask
on that makes no sense that's not
science that's politics and i am not
alone in new york city and being a
parent that's just fed up with it is
this the yunkan effect and do you think
that we're going to see a lot more
candidates like this one
yeah i do i think that that the idea
that parents matter
isn't a new one but it's one that the
democrats forgot about
we're listening to virginians it's one
of the things i'm doing today is
listening to families listening to
parents
and i just i encourage democrats to
listen to the folks that elect us
because what we're hearing over and over
again is is that they need politicians
who are going to go to work for them and
what we're seeing over and over again
right now is that the school boards
aren't working for parents and kids
school boards are working for the
education unions and here we have school
boards that are actually making it hard
for kids to come to school they won't
let them come to school
this is this is exactly what parents
across america and parents across
virginia are standing up and saying no
more we're going to elect different
folks
governor thank you so much governor
glenn yonking good to see you today
thanks for coming by the story we'll see
you soon sir
always great to be with you martha thank
you you bet hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else